y aquí viene mi segunda parte
yo defensor también del animal
no me gusta el maltrato animal
yo tengo mis animalitos los cuido
como pienso
cada uno es libre de pensar como debe
de tener unos animales
a mí me gustan los toros
los sanfermines
me gusta todo lo que va en contra vuestra
porque porque el animalito
los sanfermines por ejemplo
no sufre
van con un pastorcito que lo va guiando
habrá algún tonto lava que sí que va por ahí
le da un golpecillo vale
hay un tonto vale y hay muchos tontos
perdón por las palabra
eh por perdón por la expresión va una persona
que no piensa
o que hace algo inhumano
pero inhumano lo hay en todas las cosas
yo me imagino
el que va a los perros con trineo por la nieve
los husky
o la raza de perro que sea me da igual
quítale a ese perro que vive de ello
quítale eso el perro te dura un mes
porque se muere porque no hace su afición
o los perros can y cross
el can y cross
está hecho para que el perro vaya
y disfrute con su amo
su amo si no quiere llamarlo amo dueño
o con su compañero fiel como lo quiera llamar
para que no suene maltrato
un animal de un perro que hace can y kross
quitarle el can y cros al perro
ya no es un perro igual de feliz
un perro que hace can y kross es feliz
un perro que tira
perros que tiran de un trineo en una carrera
son felices haciendo eso
estos caballos son felices con lo que hacen
yo sí estoy seguro de que si los animales
pudiesen contestar
contestarían y lo último lo último
coches eléctricos
tú te crees que la gente
yo voy a ir a sevilla
a montarme en un coche eléctrico
a que me den una vuelta
pudiendo ir en mi propio coche
por ahí y que me diga el gps
si mira a la derecha tiene esto
si mira a la izquierda tiene esto
el atractivo de esto es el turismo
lo siento por los animalistas
que piensan que es un maltrato
tirar de un caballo
los caballos están bien cuidados
no tengo más que decir
es mi opinión
lo digo
y a la segunda parte no voy a hacer más
no voy a hacer partes
más partes yo lo que digo
tanto los perros que tiran de un trineo
tanto los que corren enganchados
o los caballos y otros animales
estoy seguro de que están mucho más cuidados
que tú y que yo
así que hay gente que respeta más
que los animalistas y palma venga
un saludo piénselo